c'est un contrôle qui est fait sur le
tour de la martinique donc des fois nous
en avoir un autre fois 2e
ça consiste à contrôler sans bien des
fois où un simple contrôle urinaire des
fois les deux et donc c'est faire
d'accord avec
président du comité régional city ce qui
fait la demande au niveau de la fld et
la fed et décide du joug qu'ils viennent
sans nous prévenir
donc c'est quelque chose de normal dans
tout ce qui se dit c'est une chose qui
est normal exactement comme les
contrôles inopinés pour les les sportifs
de haut niveau
donc au niveau du comité régional qui
crise
nos coureurs de 1re catégorie ils ont un
contrôle suivi et aussi donc nous avons
des fois les vôtres inopinés et
également sur le tour de la marque on
peut dire que les choses se passent les
choses se passent bien il nous manque
encore deux coureurs puisque
c'est tiré au sort s'est affiché 10
minutes la liste est affichée dix
minutes avant donc personne ne sait donc
c'est toujours de la confiance
confidentialité donc mais jusqu'à
présent ça se passe miel et les coureurs
il accepte sans problème